[Music]
mark nice to see you welcome to the show
thanks for making the time yeah thanks
for having me on i'm looking forward to
this
you've had a very very busy week and i
imagine most weeks are very busy perhaps
this week busier than some but before we
get to perhaps current day i wanted to
flashback just a little bit in the
course of doing research for this
conversation
i
chanced upon fencing now fencing i had
seen in connection with your name but i
had no idea that you had been as
competitive as you had been and i was
hoping you could just describe a little
bit your involvement with fencing and
for people who don't know
what makes fencing interesting what made
it interesting to you and i have
follow-up questions but i i
have taken two fencing
instructional lessons this is maybe 10
years ago and was inspired to do so
because of the writing of bruce lee of
all things but could you just describe
your background with fencing and how you
ended up competing
this is probably one of the more
interesting places to start an interview
that i've ever done
i fenced competitively when i was in
high school it's not something i've did
since i was like a little kid or
something like that but you know i've
always loved sports and
and you're just being active
i like problems that you can solve
intellectually but i
i i also just think managing your energy
and kind of being out there and being
physical it's just always been a really
important part of my life and you know
so i was looking for a you know sport
that would do this in the winter in high
school right so i i did a bunch of
running right so i did cross country and
i did tennis as well
so i started doing fencing and i don't
know i mean i i didn't do it
competitively for a super long period of
time but
the the thing that i loved about it is
it's obviously very physical and cardio
taxing right just being kind of on your
on your feet and kind of bouncing around
it's also very very mental i mean i i
have these memories when i was in my
high school chemistry classes of like
writing out sequences of moves that i
wanted to try when i was doing bouts
later after school that day and they're
just like different things that you can
do to win in multiple ways right
basically you know try to you know catch
people off guard in one position that's
like okay if they do power you then
you're still in a better position you
can get them on
on the left or something or or if they
don't then then you then you get the
touch so i just i found it to be a very
intellectual but but a good a good sport
i was never that that good at it you
know i did it competitively went to some
state competitions and stuff like that
but i don't think it would have been
good enough to do it at college for
example but it's mostly it's a fun thing
to do
the closest experience that i have is
with kendo i lived in japan for a period
of time and i did some kendo
and
i think it's it shares quite a bit in
common with fencing of course the
techniques are quite different the
slashing movements predominate in kendo
although you are allowed to stab to the
throat if you're past a certain age
which
is all a separate matter but the
idea of as they might say brazilian
jiu-jitsu this sort of position before
submission is an interesting one right
so even if your first attempt fails
you're in a superior position to execute
on your next move
and it's always struck me that as much
as people think of you as someone who
studies
or even predicts or
looks at trend lines into the future
it seems like you have quite a
background in studying the past and
that's where i wanted to go next
which was
classics it seems like you've spent
quite a bit of time studying classics
and
i was wondering if there are any books
or any figures who stick out to you
from that chapter in your life maybe
that chapter continues to this day but
if you could speak to that i figured
we'll use that as a segue to other
things
i loved classics i picked it up in
in high school as well i started
studying latin because i was so bad at
speaking french and spanish
so i i'm very interested in languages
overall but like the whole kind of
thinking on your your feet and
understanding like really quickly just i
i'm i'm actually i process things more
methodically so so latin was more my
style because you don't have to speak it
so you can just read it at whatever
whatever kind of pace makes sense and
then from there i got into greek and and
i actually thought that when i went to
college my plan at the time was to be a
classics major it turned out i took no
classics courses at harvard i just i
ended up doing psychology and computer
science where were the two areas that
that i focused on but i just loved the
discipline of classics so much in the
history i mean philosophically is sort
of the underpinning of kind of western
thought i think it's super interesting
but i've also just been very interested
in
basically people who shape the way we
live right so the historical figures who
i like learning about i'd say there's
like a set of people like
inventors
people who just create things
and and change the world through that
i'm also very interested in historical
figures who who kind of
try to
like invent or usher in new ways for for
people to live so you know i i always
thought
you know augustus was a very interesting
historical figure and i mean one of the
things i mean he's controversial for a
lot of reasons and you know you can
debate all the good and bad but one of
the things that i thought was just
really always stuck with me about what
he what he did was
when he basically stopped the wars
he you know at the time in history
there wasn't really a concept of
perpetual peace right it's like the
concept of peace that they had at the
time was like this is just the temporary
period during which your enemies are too
weak to fight you but they're going to
come back and and he basically like
ushered in this
notion of actually trying to convert a
lot of the military towards other trades
because he's like all right no we're
trying to like be more peaceful we want
to build a more positive sum economy
let's kind of do this in a way where we
can get people doing more productive
things and and i always thought that
that was just a really interesting
historical thing and in some ways has
parallels today to some of the work that
i think is going on in the tech industry
around the whole creator economy where
it's like if you just think about how
many people today basically do jobs that
they have to that they might not
actually like that much but they're
they're supporting themselves compared
to where i i think and hope that the
world is going which is just a a much
more robust
creative economy where way more people
can do things that are kind of
intellectually or physically interesting
to them and
and basically in in doing so build up
communities around that and have enough
kind of monetization and economy around
that to to kind of support that that to
me is sort of like the modern version of
kind of how do you upgrade the way that
people
live and work and to to kind of fulfill
human potential so i don't know i think
there are a lot of interesting lessons
from the past i think you can also read
into it too much but i really enjoyed it
when i studied it
where i'm going here
across a broad spectrum is trying to and
we are going to talk about the creator
economy and and
the potential of that and also questions
around it and
right now what i'm hoping to
to learn more about are some of the
influences and influences can take many
forms right one would be
books and i want to ask this is from a
profile in the new yorker from 2010 and
i remember this because i noticed it
before i read it in the new yorker at
the time which was
for a period of time i think the only
book that was on your profile on
facebook was ender's game
and i was it's wondering if you could
it is a great book it was one of my
favorites
and i was i was hoping you could
explain why ender's game and then if
there are any other
books that you have
in particular that come to mind re-read
or say gifted to other people what those
might be but if we could start with
ender's game since it is also a personal
favorite of mine i'd love to know why
ender's game
i actually don't think it has any unique
significance so i'm surprised to hear
that it was the only thing on my profile
but i do love it um it's it's a great
book i mean i think that kind of science
fiction
not just exploring
you know certain technologies but it's
also a very compelling story and has
good kind of moral lessons
there are parts of the technology and
things in it like the ansible for faster
than light communication across the
galaxy that we had a project at our
company that we named that we we had
codenamed that
because we're all focused on
communication so yeah i can't really
speak to i'm not to actually share why
it was the only thing on my profile oh
just the only book
not the only thing
i don't think it has some kind of unique
significance in my life but i love
science fiction i mean i have spent a
lot of time reading that i think it's
often a good way
to kind of understand what's possible
you know in recent years you know over
the last decade as i've gotten more into
virtual and augmented reality and
actually starting to build some of these
things more
i've certainly spent a lot of time
reading the science fiction and going
back and revisiting a bunch of the books
around that it's it's just it's really
fascinating to me to see kind of what
people predict and what the sociological
phenomena that people predict around the
stuff as well are there any books in
particular writers in particular i mean
one who comes to mind for me would be
ted chang who's written a number of
short story collections like exhalation
which
seem to include a lot of potentials kind
of right around the corner right near
near future speculative fiction
any books come to mind that you've done
just in the course of reading in the
last few years
whether related to vr ar or otherwise
there's some that are just classics
around this right so i think at this
point anyone who's interested in this
space would read ready player one and
snow crash snow crash i think rainbow's
end is one that is maybe not as commonly
cited
but i think is is maybe
the augmented reality sort of equivalent
of some of the the seminal works that
talk about virtual reality one of the
things that i think is pretty
interesting about all of these is that
they sort of posit that the
that the world is in some sort of
dystopian state and that i think is very
different from from kind of how i think
about this i think that there are all
these reasons why
it is very valuable for people to be
able to be present in another place no
matter what their their situation is i
mean i i i kind of laugh about this
sometimes when i like
you know my
family has a and we love going down to
kauai and it's beautiful there and you
know we'll be out there and i'll i love
surfing i love doing a lot of stuff but
i also you know love being in vr when
i'm when i'm there too so it's obviously
that's not you know that's not some kind
of dystopian thing but i think that just
if you look at like equalizing
opportunity across the world
you don't have to be in some kind of
dystopian situation to want to be
present with another person who you care
about or an opportunity that's better in
another place so that to me always
struck me as a very interesting theme of
that science fiction but in terms of
like exploring sociologically and
technologically what's gonna happen i've
always found it pretty fascinating
let's talk about
long-term
planning and long-term bets for a second
i i find you particularly
interesting in this respect because
you're a founder ceo
with sort of a lot of founder driven
control you're you're in a sense you
know one of the last of a generation
and you can make long-term bets and i
know when we were chatting i guess last
week a bit
you mentioned having correct me if i'm
wrong but like a 15-year roadmap
for
metaverse right
and
what i'd love to ask you is how you
manage say the short-term or the
intermediate term with within the
company with employees right because if
you look at say instagram whatsapp the
the bets paid off but at the time
there's a lot of scrutiny you know the
media had sort of had a field day and by
and large were wrong
but i'm wondering
since those types of bets are not
necessarily obvious in the moment to
everyone involved
but how do you think about
managing
internally
when you are making these long-term bets
it's hard and i don't think that there's
just one way to do it yeah you know
obviously people are psychologically
much more
interested and capable of focusing on a
long-term outcome when they feel secure
in the near-term so when there's a lot
of near-term thrash or you know
prospects don't look good or
the market is down overall you know even
if that's not specific to your company
even if it's a kind of broader thing i
think that that that definitely
strains people's time horizons yeah but
i think that good leadership is you you
try to get people excited about where
you're going you obviously you can't
just ignore the short term there's a lot
of stuff that we need to get done there
and at this point you know it's a
it's a pretty big company so i mean as
one of our our board members says we
need to be able to walk and chew gum at
the same time which is probably a
simplification
one of the things that i've sort of
personally
learned over the last you know 18 years
of running the the company is like
i i remember when i was getting started
feeling like you
weren't understood
kind of feels bad i think that there's
there's a normal human impulse which is
like
you want to be understood i think that's
that's partially why people want to
express themselves and why communication
is so important is like people at some
level have this intrinsic desire to be
kind of understood and belong and like
feel like they're
belong with the people around them and
obviously being in a state where you
you're kind of something that you're
trying to do is kind of fundamentally
misunderstood or that people don't
believe in it can be tough
but
i don't after going through a bunch of
these cycles i actually feel like i've
trained myself
to do
to kind of see it the opposite way which
is if i'm doing something that feels too
well understood for too long then i feel
like i'm just being complacent so you
know after after even gone through a
bunch of these different cycles you know
a lot of things that are just not
controversial today but at the time
people thought were crazy right so
taking the the service initially from
being a a college website to not buying
instagram or whatsapp which were you
know billions of dollars for the
acquisitions but like at the time people
were like what you know i remember i
think it was jon stewart or or colbert
but they did a segment that was making
fun of the instagram acquisition that
was like what it's like you bought
instagram for a billion dollars of money
are you kidding me so i think some of
these things it's like you just you kind
of go through a bunch of these and you
you
have the conviction to kind of push back
on the on the world a little bit and say
okay no we're gonna we're gonna get
through this and and
come out you know 18 months 24 months
with something that we believe in and
and after that happens a few times
you kind of understand that that could
happen i think most people still will
get more of these bets wrong than right
so it's not like
i think it's obviously very important to
not not get too overconfident with this
but but at this point i i kind of feel
like
if people fully feel like they
understand what we are as a company and
what we're doing then i'm not pushing it
hard enough and that actually now i'm at
the point where like that feels bad to
me so i kind of like want to push us
into the zone which is like okay let's
let's kind of constantly be doing
something that can be doubted because if
we're not then what are we doing right
it's like we have this huge opportunity
to to be able to you know do exciting
things and help invent things and create
things for the world and
if it's obvious to everyone that we're
kind of going to be able to do each of
the things that we're working on then
i don't feel like we're kind of making
the most of what we need to do i'm not
sure that that answers the original
question around you know how do you get
people through it but i actually think a
lot of this
how do you get an organization of 100
000 people through something is about
managing your own psychology and about
managing your team's psychology for sure
you know one of the things that i've
always found is you can pretty much i
think get an organization through in a
team through
almost any challenge as long as you can
maintain good cohesion so you know the
it's the external stuff that doesn't
bother me that much you know people can
criticize us i mean i i obviously you
know if they're people i respect i care
a lot about that and want to want to
make sure we do better but it doesn't it
doesn't like make me not sleep at night
when our stock price goes down that
doesn't make me not sleep at night when
there's a new competitor that doesn't
make me not sleep at night if there's an
issue on my team
and people aren't and there isn't good
cohesion
then i'm not sleeping well until i
resolve that yeah it goes back to the
very first thing we were talking about
with you know fencing it's it's
intellectual and you're managing your
energy but i think like in order to get
through these things and and and build
big long-term things you kind of just
need to i think you need to take care of
yourself and you need to take care of
your core team and then like that and
basically in doing so you can i think
lead a pretty large organization through
some pretty difficult times to do some
pretty awesome stuff i think that it's
intellectual it's energy and it's about
kind of training yourself to be
uncomfortable
let's talk about the the training
yourself to be uncomfortable or to
become more comfortable with discomfort
does anything come to mind just in terms
of managing your psychology for my own
psychology the way that i try to manage
this stuff is i wake up in the morning
and you get like whatever emails you
have of like stuff that's going on in
the world right so it's world events
it's team events whatever trends we're
seeing across our our products
and often in there there's a fair amount
of
bad news and like new things that i need
to absorb
one of the things i found that just for
kind of managing my myself
is that
if i try to just go straight into the
day
it's like almost every morning when i
wake up and like read read through my my
emails and get the news it's like
it's almost like getting punched with
sort of like a ton of new context and
it's like okay i need to like
internalize this so i found that
basically doing
something physical
and in something that's like meditative
to take my mind off of it for like an
hour so then i can reset and go do work
is really important so that's why you
know things like foiling or surfing have
been really important to me because you
know when you're out there in the water
it's like pretty hard to focus on
anything else right it's i mean it's
like you when you're on the board you
you're focused on making sure you stay
on the board and don't mess something up
and especially if you're if you're kind
of towing or something like that there's
not a whole lot of downtime yeah
i found that for my own performance is
significantly better when i have
something like that that's like
meditative and
and physical and and allows me to kind
of output some energy and then i can
come back in and it's almost like i'll
have subconsciously settled all of the
things that that have sort of all the
news that have happened in the world now
it's like okay let's go deal with it
yeah no obviously if there's something
that's really an emergency i'm not gonna
you know go to a sport or something i'll
go deal with it and obviously part of
life is you you don't always get to
control your schedule and that's kind of
how that goes but you know when i
compare kind of how i do
on the days when i kind of get to have
some time to soak that in or to to kind
of have an outlet versus
just like jumping right in i find them
often like stewing and bad news or
something and then i just i i like i'm
not i'm not as productive so i think
that's sort of my own personal way that
i try to to manage situations like this
but obviously
a key part of this is like having an
awesome team and and it's not it's not
you know primarily about me at this
point you know it's a big company and we
have awesome people who are who are
running all these different groups so i
get that what i'm what i'm saying kind
of how i've worked out the system for
myself isn't necessarily something that
would work for a lot of other people
i think that the meditative palette
cleanser makes sense though especially
if you're talking about things like
foiling where the
consequence of a lapse of attention on
what you're doing has immediate
penalties yeah so it's regulating in a
sense maybe i'm not strong-willed enough
or like or or calm enough to just do
straight-up meditation it's like i
actually need to put myself in a
situation where it's difficult to not
focus on that thing
yeah but i don't know i mean i think
part of this too and i do think managing
energy is an interesting thing i mean
some of the the folks who i work with
the company they say this lovingly but i
think that they sometimes refer to my
attention as the eye of sauron in that
basically
you have this unending amount of energy
to go work on on something and if you
and if you like point that at any given
team you will just burn them but at the
same time right it's managing that so
that way i can like manage my own energy
and diffuse it well enough so that way
it's like okay i i have the thing that
i'm focused on that that day and i it's
really important to me that i can
as often as possible manage my schedule
so i can actually focus on the things
that i'm naturally thinking about i just
think the engagement that you get of
having like a an immediate feedback loop
around thinking about something then
going to getting to go talk to the
people who are working on this is so
much better than like going and
scheduling a meeting that you'll have
three weeks later when i mean maybe the
topic will still be important but it's
not like what's going on at that time
yeah getting that balance right is an
important thing for sustainability for
the organization as well yeah for sure
we may come back to energy management
we're going to touch a lot of subjects
we're going to bounce from the
professional
to the personal and everything in
between let's touch on some things that
are
kind of top of mind or might be top of
mind right now because i certainly have
a lot of questions related to say the
metaverse and a longer term roadmap
and you know we chatted briefly
prior to this about engineering versus
science problems so i think i'd love to
unpack that at some point but let me ask
a really specific question
first and that's related to
kinesthetic feedback and engagement
right so one thing that struck me about
ready player one especially in the in
the cinematic version so the movie
itself is that you have this incredible
tactile environment where they're
grabbing objects and interacting with
objects feeling impact and so on
but then you see
them cut to an external shot of someone
in a say trailer where where they
wouldn't actually have that kind of
feedback even though they have haptic
suits
in
ready player one what do you see as sort
of the road map for
that type of interactivity though like
the more i thought about this and the
more i realized well surface level
stimulation
may not be
quite as immersive as people would hope
for do we need to wait for some type of
neuralink type of
computer brain interface where we're
actually stimulating the brain
and not simulating but actually
producing sort of the perception of
kinesthetic engagement how do you think
about the future of that type of
hardware and interaction
so i think that there's a pretty long
arc there and it's also just pretty
amazing how how good of a sense of
presence you can you can get even with
certain things being
pretty raw or out of place right the the
original
devices that we had for virtual reality
didn't even have hand presence right
they just had basically the headset and
it had this wire so you kind of had this
wire like wrapped around your neck
because it had to go to a computer to to
power the thing and it just over like
every year we basically like
knocked down one or two more barriers
right so then we got quest which you got
rid of the wire you got it so that now
you could run virtual reality
at you know 150th or 1 100th of the
compute power than what you have in a
powerful desktop
on on just a you know with a mobile chip
on your on your headset
then we got hands
and
the first set of hands were basically
controllers
but now you're actually getting actual
hand tracking with like all 10
fingers being able to be tracked in real
time you know in the next version that's
coming out we have you know sensors for
your eyes so you can make realistic eye
contact with someone in in virtual
reality and you know i mean just
thinking about
to what extent you can do without some
of this stuff i mean think about all the
zoom calls that you've been on over the
last couple of years during covid
there's no real eye contact over video
conference yeah because your your
cameras are in different places so yeah
and even without that you know it still
gets you pretty far so in vr today
adding realistic eye contact each of
these things it's like
you kind of almost don't realize that
you're missing them and then when you
have them you're like whoa that's that's
like a really core part of the
the human experience is being able to
you know make eye contact and hold eye
contact with someone and like have that
gaze
so i think you'll just add more things
over time right more realistic
expressions
more realistic avatars
you know going from from kind of cartoon
and stylistic and fun to photo realistic
and having having that work and then at
some point i think you will get haptics
and you know the way that we kind of
think about you know haptic glove for
example you know screens have
resolutions right you think about how
many pixels are on the screen and you
can actually think about haptics in your
hand or anywhere else is basically also
having a resolution it's like how many
how many kind of you know pin points can
it make across your your hand and your
hand is super sensitive so it can
actually
your actual
physical hand can have a very high
amount of resolution for haptics but
when we first start getting haptics
they're not going to have that high of
resolution but it's still going to be
amazing and then every year they're
gonna they're gonna get better and
better and better so i think that
there's like quite a a far
road map on this which is partially what
makes it super exciting right it's like
you can have realistically a 15-year
road map of like all right what is it
going to take to deliver the the kind of
virtual reality presence that you want
to be you know feel like you're
physically there with another person at
the same time augmented reality is a
whole separate set of problems because
now you're putting a hologram in the
real world so that's kind of a similar
thing there but being able to just work
on a project that's like a 15-year
project where there's a lot of it as an
engineering problem that you just need
to go build but a lot of it is also
unknown right so there's like six or
seven key unknowns that we just have
like multiple teams going out and trying
to attack different different approaches
at that i just think it's a it's a very
fascinating and fun way to to make
progress and of course each year you're
intercepting and launching a new product
so i find this to be some of the most
exciting work that i've ever gotten to
be a part of and i hope that for
the rest of my career that i get to
engage in more projects that are sort of
you know longer term oriented with this
mix of engineering and science and kind
of continual milestones i think it's
just a great way to make progress in the
world
i'd love to ask some more questions
about
metaverse
and
uh also the recent announcement related
to instagram and nfts just to touch on
that and then we're gonna go back and
fill in with some
some backstory and of some family
questions if you're open to that so
as i'm looking at
the metaverse and have been
observing fairly closely web 3
developments and nfts and so on in the
last handful of years
i've been thinking quite a lot about
your long-term planning and then
how you must think about sort of
secondary effects tertiary effects of
these technological advances
and then i've also thought about
i think it was andy grove who had paired
metrics so he would have like like a
primary outcome metric that they were
tracking then they would look for kind
of correlated
impacts that they could track that were
you know undesirable or should be
addressed in advance and i'll give you
an example so playing with
oculus i was very impressed with the
technology because i used a very early i
want to say prototype but version years
ago and the advances are really
tremendous and i had an opportunity to
chat with a friend of mine who
unbeknownst to me
at some point and i'm blanking on the
exact game
title but he was something like second
in the world or third in the world in
mini golf
and that was i want to say a year year
and a half ago now he's not even in the
top 500 right so there's there's clearly
a
large demand for this the number of
users is increasing rapidly and it's
still early right it's really really
early yeah now when i used the
technology most recently
and i had
several ligaments torn on my knee so i
had the experience of actually engaging
with it sitting on a couch which was
fascinating because it was my first time
not mapping out sort of the playing
area and walking around so i actually
had the ability to test it as somebody
who was sort of mobility restricted
which was amazing when i came out of the
experience it took a while for my eyes
and brain to readjust to sort of the
depth perception of objects around me
and i was chatting with this this friend
john he said oh yeah you know it takes
about two to three months and then you
adjust completely to that and i'm
wondering what types of
societal changes maybe physical
adaptations you're tracking as more and
more people come online and begin to
spend more and more time using say vr
the framework that you're talking about
about having
goals and metrics to track those goals
and then counter metrics is i think a
really important one that we basically
encode into all of our teams across the
company right they're basically things
that we're that we're trying to
that we think are good
if basically
if can enable more connection or more
different things across the company but
then there are definitely there are kind
of counter metrics in all these areas
that where they were tracking to make
sure that you know we don't exceed or
don't increase
negative effects
for vr specifically the biggest issue
that that people report is still this
feeling of motion sickness and
the the basic issue just to kind of
break it down is
your
eye now eyes are not are not computers
but you can kind of think about it as a
refresh rate right where it's like if if
something changes in the world it'll
kind of take you know five to ten
milliseconds for different people for
you to
sort of recognize that and if you think
about what's technically happening
with with vr basically you have to
render this whole
world continuously
and if you
basically if if a person changes their
head position or eye position and it
expects the image to be different but
then by the time that their
sakad is is done which is you know what
it's called basically you're kind of eye
refocusing
if we haven't
rendered correctly what you would kind
of expect to be in that space then it it
creates this real feeling of discomfort
over time right and it kind of it's not
like you miss one frame and you feel
terrible for most people but it's over
time if you're not doing that
efficiently then that creates this
feeling that that it creates a it's a
real physical feeling of discomfort so
and this is partially why
the early versions of the vr headsets
needed to be plugged into a computer
because they needed to in order to be
able to render a world that quickly you
needed a lot of computing power so it's
this it's this tremendous engineering
challenge to now be able to do that so
much more efficiently that you're doing
that on a mobile chip which is you know
150th or 1 100th is as powerful as the
desktop things but get that
to work really well i would say that
that problem
is not fully solved yet but it's getting
better in every generation and
people aren't computers and not everyone
is the same and people have different
sensitivity to this stuff so you know
some people if a headset is running at
60 frames per second that won't bother
them but other people i mean at the
other end of the spectrum if a headset
is running at 120 frames per second they
may still perceive some glitchiness and
you know for most people if you get to
72 or 90 you're you're in pretty good
shape but you know there are like
outliers and people are not all the same
and you know at the end of the day
making this a technology that can be
comfortable for basically everyone is
going to be a really critical part of
making this happen so that's probably
the biggest effect that we see
some of the other stuff
like you mentioned i think you just need
some more kind of a longitudinal study
right it's tough to exactly understand
all the effects of anything right up
front but you want to be mindful of that
and and kind of and be open to the fact
that what you're doing could have issues
and that you want to improve those
issues and you know we try to research
that stuff and and basically try to
continuously improve it but that's the
biggest thing that we're tracking right
now
looking at societal changes we could
look at that for a second then we'll
come back to instagram
i've i've been
very engaged in watching say axi
infinity as an example and play to earn
in different
different forms
and it's been
pretty mind-boggling to see for instance
that there are so many players in the
philippines who are earning income that
they can now impact large elections
right as a constituent
and
i'm wondering
how you see this developing and this is
certainly meta is going to be a primary
player they're going to be
other players but where
if we get to the point where and please
poke holes in this if you have a
different view of things but if we get
to a point where there's almost a
universal basic income
provided by the
broad spectrum of jobs that you can have
in the metaverse or online
what do you think some of the societal
effects will be of that it seems to be
certainly growing faster than i ever
could have imagined even though a lot of
it is maybe not right in my backyard but
it's certainly on a global level
it seems to be expanding really quickly
i'd love to hear you speak to that
in any capacity
i don't interpret this
as a universal basic income
i think what we're actually going to see
is just the creation of a lot of
different worlds that have different
rules so i think we'll we'll kind of
explore and and people will get to
spend more time
in in worlds that
there are very different rule sets
around but everything from from
different physics literally to like kind
of how how you can move through the
space
to
you know different modes of governance
right so you know one thing that i think
is pretty important and that i hope that
we can build into
the horizon platform that you know it's
the social platform that we're building
is the idea that anyone can create a
space but then
spaces can be nested in other spaces
right so you can basically create a you
know a building or a store and then that
can be inside a city that that someone
else creates and then there's the
question there
of okay well how do you govern that
right who gets to say and what policies
who can enter it how do taxes work like
what's the basic business model of that
space what are the design codes around
like what like what are you allowed to
build there you know all these different
dimensions and basically the the
physical world is
i mean there's there's a lot of it but
it is at the end of the day you know
more finite than what we're gonna have
with the virtual world so you know not
everyone can kind of get to be the mayor
of of their own virtual space and see
how that evolves but i think part of
what we're going to get to see
is we're going to have you know whether
they could be you know young people in
philippines or anywhere else around the
world experimenting with basically
creating
worlds that are not just a single space
or an experience but but actually like
an environment or a polity in a way that
other people can can kind of be a part
of and i think that there will be sort
of
pretty interesting innovation you know
social and economic and in governance
innovation as long as this gets designed
in a good way so i guess more than any
specific policy idea i think this could
end up being a way to basically explore
a lot of different ideas and and kind of
see which of these different
environments that evolve are going to be
appealing to people in different ways i
so i think that's going to be wild to
watch play out and it's one of the
things that i'm i'm really looking
forward to
are there any
societal shifts or changes not
necessarily
catalyzed by meta but just that you see
coming
or plausibly coming that you guys are
trying to get ahead of or think about
just in terms of of mitigating problems
later is there is there anything that
comes to mind
i'm not sure if this is exactly what
you're getting at but one big shift that
i think is happening
is
the rise of distributed work i don't
view that as a problem i think it's good
because i mean there's there's just a
lot of research that shows that people's
opportunities social economic and
otherwise are generally pretty anchored
to physically where they are yeah and i
think sometimes people
draw this juxtaposition of there's like
the digital world in the real world
that's not actually how i think about it
i think that there's a physical world
and a digital world and the real world
is actually both yeah and increasingly i
think people will use these technologies
to be able to be present
in places that they physically can't be
and i think that's really powerful right
it's like we're doing this podcast and
we're not sitting next to each other
physically but it like feels like we're
we're we're here and we're kind of
having a live conversation and in the
future you know maybe you know five
years from now if we were doing this
i'll have ar glasses and you know
hologram version of me will be on the
couch next to you and i think that that
will be even better than what we're
doing right now so i think that through
video chat you can have moments where
you feel present but i think through
things like virtual and augmented
reality when you can like have an office
and someone can be walking through it as
a hologram
even though they're physically in a
different place i think that you'll just
be able to much more naturally unlock
more of the opportunities both social
and economic and i guess other others as
well
of being able to be around people and be
present no matter where you actually are
so people will be free to to kind of
live where they want maybe where their
family physically is in a country that
they grew up in but they'll have all the
opportunities that will be available
around the world so that i think is is
awesome i think it's one of the most
promising things about the future and
one of the things that i'm trying to do
is
sort of take the conversation in a
different direction we actually recently
did this exercise at our company
where we were thinking about okay we're
coming up on almost 100 000 people soon
in our company and
we kind of think about our values as a
company is like our cultural operating
system right it's like how do we how do
we basically get work done well and
continue to build the things that we
that we need to build and you know a big
part of the the values and i'd love to
talk through them here and i haven't
this is actually the the first podcaster
or any public thing that i've done where
i've discussed
any of the values so i think it'd
probably be pretty interesting to go
through it sure one of them is basically
we've rolled out this value called
live in the future which is basically
about the world is moving towards being
distributed first and we you know both
because we think that that's a good
trend for how we work
and because we
aspire to play a role in building all
the technology to to enable that through
virtual reality augmented reality
metaverse
software
and infrastructure and like avatars to
express herself
we have this thing that we want people
inside the company to eat your own dog
food right we want people to basically
build they use the things that we're
building internally as part of how we
work because that's also it gets us in a
faster feedback loop to make those tools
better for for everyone else around the
world but i mean that's one of the the
six values that we just rolled out i i
actually think it might be interesting
to go through the others too but but
up to you
yeah please let's go through them and
then i'll i'll have some questions about
them i'm sure
you know some of them we kept but we're
just changing
how we execute them so one thing that i
think our company is pretty well known
for is having the value of move fast
i've always believed that values are
only useful
if you can
like legitimately disagree with them
right so i i've always thought like
values like be honest are like not that
helpful because like of course you have
to be honest right it's like i feel bad
even needing to write that down if you
have to write that down then something
something kind of went wrong but i don't
know any good company that doesn't that
doesn't focus on kind of honesty or
demand that of of their of their
employees so from my perspective that's
not like a useful
you know if you only get to write down
like five or six concepts to to kind of
program into your culture you want them
to be things that good companies can
reasonably do differently
and i think part of this is that good
values you need to be able to give
something up in order to get them so
around move fast you know we've always
had this this question it's like you
can't just tell people to move fast the
question is like what's the deal like
what are you what are you willing to
give up and famously it used to be move
fast and break things and the the idea
was that we tolerated some amount of
bugs in the software
in order to basically encourage people
to move quickly because it's like moving
fast i think is the key to learning
right it's like you want to increase the
iteration cycle so you can get feedback
from from the people you serve quickly
and and then incorporate that into the
product so we would literally get into
situations
where you know it's competitors of us
would ship you know once a year once
every six months and we'd ship code
every day and it's like of course we're
gonna learn faster and we're gonna build
something better if you're shipping
something every day so the question is
what are you willing to give up
so it used to be we would tolerate some
amount of defects in the product now it
got to the point that as the company
grew
that we were producing so many bugs that
going back and fixing them was actually
slowing us down more than than we were
speeding up so i still thought okay like
moving fast this is still like a really
important thing we've got to change how
we do it so
we we kind of evolved to
building a somewhat less sexy phrase
move fast with stable infrastructure and
basically the new the new bet was we're
going to invest disproportionately and
building up good infrastructure and
abstractions inside our company so that
way the average engineer who comes here
is going to be much faster and more
productive at getting things done than
in other places and
you know at a scale of almost 100 000
people i think what this really means
now
is like methodically
i don't know it's like companies just
add process over time right it's like
and it's all good intention you know
for the most part right it's like people
are trying to you know make sure that we
don't repeat mistakes that we've made so
you just have this like checklist of
things that everyone needs to do before
they can ship anything
but
most companies don't have a counter
process to that to basically garbage
collect and remove processes that are no
longer that useful so part of what i'm
really focused on now is is just
methodically going through and making
sure all of the different processes that
we've built up as a company still serve
us well
in kind of empowering a an effort to go
do that so you know so now that's that's
kind of what move fast is focused on
should we keep going you want to do the
next yeah let's keep going all right so
let's do it the second one is it's
focused on long-term impact where on the
one hand you want a very fast cycle time
to learn quickly but on the other hand
you want to always keep people focused
on the prize right and and long term and
you know one thing that's sort of
is unfortunate you know we we had a
version of this before that we just said
focus on impact
but
a lot of people especially as the
company grew interpreted that to mean
do something that would make an impact
in this six-month cycle right so that
way like when you have your performance
review your manager can point to
something good that you did and like and
you get promoted and it's like oh god
that's like definitely not what we're
trying to do right it's not even like
obviously it's good if you can have an
impact in the near term but but it's you
know you want to be able to
have a faster duration speed to learn
quickly but
it's not always important to to kind of
deliver something every six months you
want to you want to make sure that
you're you're focusing and improving
things for the long term so you know
we've actually made a bunch of changes
to our culture we changed performance
management and the the performance cycle
that people have
from every six months to now it's just
once a year to make it so the time
frames that people have or longer
the next one is a new one that we added
that we call build awesome things and
the the idea here is that
i actually think that there's a pretty
big difference between
things that are valuable
and things that are
like awe-inspiring and amazing and i
kind of think that our company has been
pretty good at building things that a
lot of people use and like
but
for a combination of reasons we we just
haven't focused
quite as much until the last few years
especially as we've worked on a lot of
this metaverse work in virtual reality
and things like that we haven't focused
as much on things that are just like awe
inspiring and i actually think there's
this balance where you need to do both
right it's i mean you can't do things
that are just that are just all
inspiration and no substance but i also
think you can go too far in the other
direction of just doing things that
that are useful
but
i think a lot of what the world needs
right now is inspiration you know there
are a lot of things in our lives in
modern day that work pretty well but i
think a lot of what we sort of lack is a
positive vision for the future a lot of
the metaverse work to me kind of has
that level of inspiration
that's partially why it's why i find it
super exciting we talked about live in
the future that's mostly focused on
being a great distributed work workforce
i mean i you know from the early days of
covet i sort of
made this
kind of tried to put a flag in the
ground that we were gonna even after
covet is done we're gonna
by the end of this decade hopefully have
50 or more of the company basically
working distributed and working remotely
and i still think that that will be
awesome and just unlock opportunity get
access to more talent
and then the last two are basically you
know be direct and respect your
colleagues which i i find as the company
grows one of my colleagues baz has this
saying that we're in danger of nicing
ourselves to death i think like as
organizations grow
there's a sort of politeness that comes
in where when you're just working with a
small set of people and you're
comfortable with them you can you can
actually be a lot more blunt and direct
and
you know cheryl always says that the
amount of progress that we make is
directly proportional to the number of
hard conversations that we're willing to
have but it's like as companies grow i
think like it's tougher to kind of give
hard feedback so i think just kind of
trying to build that into the cultural
operating system which is like we're
just gonna really reward and focus on
being direct with each other i think is
a really important thing
and then the last one you know i
realized i've been talking for like 10
minutes straight at this point but but i
think this is the first time i've talked
about this stuff publicly so i you know
i have a lot a lot of things to say when
we rebranded the company to meta we had
this internal question of like what
should we which we call our employees
and someone actually emailed douglas
hofsteder right the renowned author and
thinker and and he he he wrote back and
was like it should be metamates and
so internally i kind of felt like if
douglas hofstetter thinks we should be
metamates then who am i to disagree with
that so our last value is meta metamates
me which is it's sort of this adaptation
from this old naval saying ship shipmate
self and it's it's just like as the
company grows you want to make sure that
the people stay focused on the long term
and the whole enterprise and then their
their teams and taking care of of of of
their teams but then and also take care
of themselves i think that having that
as a framework is pretty important so
i'm i'm happy to go into more detail on
any of these but i also want to be you
know aware that this is a quite a long
answer and monologue as it is so so
wherever you want to go with this
yeah let's pick up on it and then i have
a whole bunch of other things i'd love
to get into but with respect to the
values so i've seen and looked very
closely at the values of say amazon
which you'd have iterated but that bezos
put together and others and i think the
degree to which values end up the
for lack of a better term sort of
operating system of people at a company
varies widely company to company
and
i'd love to know
how or if you are and you mentioned one
example of the longer performance review
time frames right incentivizing
these behaviors right you have a team
that is sort of determining how to
facilitate
supporting these values throughout the
organization so that they
they do have more
saturation so to speak
each of these is basically coupled with
an operational effort so we we have a
set of work that we do
that's
it's like move fast is the work and it's
basically
it's actually something that i'm pretty
engaged in where i will just routinely
go and sit down with
largely engineering leaders but but also
you know folks across the company and
ask them okay well what is slowing you
down right so in addition to the product
reviews that i'll do where we'll talk
about okay what are the decisions we
should be making or you know what should
we be investing in it's i think it's
useful to often just sit down with
people and have a whole conversation
they're like all right what what are the
things that are that are basically
causing you to move more slowly and then
i view a bunch of my job
as ceo but then also we have other
people who just work on this to try to
go remove those obstacles you know and
obviously we have to do it in a way that
helps fit the other goals of the company
right so people are saying hey you know
it's it would it would make me
be able to go faster if i just didn't
have to care about this issue you know
if that's an important issue then you
know obviously we're not gonna
you just say no right it's like let's
figure out how we can care about that
issue and do this as efficiently as
possible but i do think that there's you
can apply
sort of a methodical amount of
kind of you can apply energy
methodically over a long period of time
towards
basically oiling or greasing the the the
wheels in the in the organization in the
direction that you want and i think you
can
get it done over time yeah i remember
when i was first learning about running
an organization i had this conversation
with this guy dan rosensweig he was the
ceo of yahoo at the time and um
he's great he's a is a great person and
he he told me this thing that will
always stick with me which is that every
organization sucks
but you get to choose the ways in which
your organization sucks and which is
maybe the most negative possible way of
putting it but i think it's basically if
you want to move fast on certain
dimensions you can but you only get a
few things like that right so i think
it's you know if you want to optimize
moving fast we can do that if we want to
optimize being distributed first we can
do that but maybe you get like five of
these and and like you you and we are
very focused on operationalizing them
and and making sure that each of these
values is backed up by like real
work streams that we have or decisions
that we make or processes that we make
and i mentioned changing the performance
management tool
for live in the future one of the big
things that we're doing is
you know i don't just want
your teams to be working distributed and
working over video conference i also
want them to be using workrooms and
using their their kind of vr headsets
workrooms is this product it's it's the
vr product
that we built for collaboration i think
it's it's great it's it's early still
but it's it's fascinating it's it's like
you can you're in a meeting and you're
sitting around a table and even though
the kind of fidelity isn't quite as
photorealistic on the avatars yet as you
know say the conversation that we're
having now the fact that you can sit
around a table and you can see people's
gestures and
you can have a side conversation so if
there's 10 people around
the table you can turn to the person
next to them and ask them a question
there could be multiple conversations
going on in the room like a normal room
but obviously you can't do anything like
that over a video conference there are a
bunch of things like that that actually
make it in some ways feel more real
already than video conferences even
though the people are still very the
avatars are still very stylized and
cartoony so but we basically have a rule
that everyone who's in
you know across the company
who's in leadership or management
should be
basically doing at least like one
standing meeting a week in work rooms
right because that's like okay we want
to get the feedback loop going on that
right it's like that way that that team
now is overwhelmed with feedback on how
to how to get it to be even better but i
think the one of the outcomes of this is
like
i think workrooms is going to probably
learn what they need to do to be a great
product a lot faster than a lot of
others in the space so i think that's
kind of one way to operationalize these
but yeah you got to operationalize them
if you want them to be real otherwise
they're just words that you put on a
website somewhere
i want to say that one thing that came
up repeatedly in the course of doing
homework for this conversation was how
relentlessly product focused you are and
i heard multiple anecdotes i don't know
if they're apocryphal
i can imagine them happening though
where if you'd be walking down the
street and some kid would be like
facebook sucks and you'd walk over and
be like oh yeah well tell me like show
me why it sucks like show me and then
you'd take like 25 notes and the next
day team would get a long list of things
from having actually sat down with
someone for like a half hour 45 minutes
and having them walk you through
their experience and i do think that
i'd love to ask a few more questions
about just web3 in general
and then maybe backstep for a second to
ask you about a number of other facets
in your life with with instagram and
nfts so i know that the web 3 is getting
a lot of
air time right now and you know i just
came from a separate conference where
like every conversation involved web 3 i
and it strikes me that
you know web 2 web 3
decentralized centralized are going to
coexist i mean i'm no expert but it
seems that people want curation in many
cases they want trusted third parties i
don't want to always be my own bank it's
there's there are good reasons why i use
banks instead of
not taking on all those responsibilities
myself and i'm wondering how let's just
say in the case of instagram
some challenges that perhaps use you
foresee
and i can imagine for instance if people
can turn hypothetically posts into nfts
how that might affect
let's just say
content moderation
and
safety precautions and so on if they
actually have ownership
of their posts right so i mean this is a
hypothetical that i'm just kind of
throwing out there but what type of
challenges do you foresee
coming up in the near term or in the
long term
the one that you just mentioned is is i
think a really fundamental one and at
some level
you can make things censorship resistant
which has a bunch of equities and
there's certainly a lot of people who
feel like their their expression is
restricted online more than they would
like
but that also prevents
if if you really can't stop people from
expressing things then how are you going
to fight against terrorism or child
exploitation or things that people think
are like really awful even the people
who generally want more stuff to to be
allowed online so i think that they're
having the
really removing the ability
for anyone
to do any kind of moderation at all
in a broader platform i think is
problematic i think in something like
messaging we don't expect the people who
run our messaging platforms you know
whether it's us or apple or whoever to
to go kind of moderate a message that
you send in private but it's it's sort
of this distinction between the living
room and the town square right if you're
in in a space that's a broader space
then i think that there is a little more
need to make sure that things conform to
the values that society wants right and
and reducing things that are just really
that i think everyone agrees are bad
like terrorism and child exploitation
and bullying and things like that
but taking a step back on your question
around web 3 and
nfts i commit a lot of this
from the perspective of
thinking about the metaverse and how to
make it more interoperable in a better
environment for creators right because
right now so i do think that there's
there's an interesting conversation to
have around you know instagram and
facebook and
what to do there but i kind of i tend to
think about that as sort of how can you
help bootstrap a creative economy in
these
2d social apps that will be much much
bigger once you get to the the um this
metaverse vision over time and um i
think the reason why interoperability is
so important
is because
like i imagine this case right so you're
you're basically you know we get to a
point where instead of spending three
hours a day on video conference calls
you're now spending that same time in in
basically feeling like you're actually
present with someone either because
they're a hologram on your couch with
augmented reality or you're in virtual
reality in something like workrooms but
a future version of it where you're like
actually you feel like you're physically
there with them around a table okay so
now in a world where you're spending a
few hours a day doing that
you're going to care about how you
express yourself right so that's both
the avatar right do you show up as a
photo realistic version of yourself or
you're a dragon are you kind of a
stylized version but a lot of this is
going to be like okay how do we choose
to express ourselves as through the
clothing and what we wear and what we
put on
but now imagine
that you know basically
every app that you go to
anything that you do to express yourself
is you get a sweatshirt it's in an app
you can't actually bring that to another
app
that would just be massively stifling
for the whole creative economy because
now as a as a consumer you're not going
to want to buy a lot of you know
sweatshirts because they're not going to
be that useful because you can't bring
them between places and because you're
not going to want to buy that much it's
going to be less useful for creators and
fewer people are going to be able to
make a living basically designing these
kind of experiences or virtual
architecture virtual clothes or
different things like that so the
ability to be able to
take how you want to express yourself
and take your stuff with you between
these different experiences i think is
just like a really key kind of technical
principle and standards thing to
hopefully achieve with the metaverse so
i hope we can get there and in order to
push in that direction i think it's
helpful to start sooner in things like
instagram and facebook by by supporting
the communities that are that are doing
things like nfts that way you can get to
minting you can get to bring your stuff
around between these different places
but i do think that the challenges that
you're mentioning where all systems i
think end up being some some combination
of some element of decentralized and
centralized i think actually a lot of
new systems just basically create value
by decentralizing and creating more
opportunity in some area by creating a
new tool that a lot of people use
but
i think we'll need to get the balance
right and that's something that
i i just i'm probably more optimistic
about the web3 stuff than most other
people who are running these big
companies so i would i'm trying to push
us to be more forward leaning on that
and
our kind of fundamental belief is that
if we if we create more use cases
where creators can start to do this
stuff then
you'll get more experimentation and
you'll also just get a bigger creative
economy over over time which i i think
is a huge part of the goal
yeah for sure well that's going to be
it's going to be exciting to watch i
have to say also that
doing a bit of biographical research
looking at your trajectory having known
quite a bit already
it's
incredible to me
how much complexity you have learned to
grapple with in the sense that
now on a global stage if there are
conflicts or state actors who want to
engage or need to engage
you know meta is almost
always it would seem going to be
on the playing field in some capacity
and it's it's just very impressive to me
that
you have
from the very beginning
reached this point where you're
grappling with
with so many different layers of
complexity so i just wanted to say that
first and foremost i appreciate that i
can't even imagine i have enough trouble
dealing with the complexity of a of a
tiny team of fewer than 10 people
much less a hundred thousand and then
the global stage
one thing i did want to ask about so
i had a no fellaini on this podcast a
long time ago you put a lot of time and
thought into the oversight board what is
your
assessment of of how that's how that's
going
well i think it's early but i i think
the key here
one of the things that i think has been
really promising
is that
society needs
a network of different institutions
that it feels like are legitimate or
have some legitimacy for making
decisions
in order to basically accept the
decisions and feel like they're fair and
i think one basic issue that we've found
ourselves in is that there's just no way
that any single private company
should be responsible for arbitrating
so many questions of social values right
between you know free expression and
safety or you know locking things down
to ensure privacy versus making sure
that the marketplace can be open and
competitive right it's like these it's
like these these are real issues and
there's equities on all sides and
there's no single decision that any
company can make on any of them that i
think is going to be universally
accepted so i think therefore
you you really want to
not set up a situation
where
where one company is
kind of has to make a lot of these
decisions by themselves that's why i
want to create this oversight board i i
recognize that we're always going to
have to be kind of the first line and
we're going to be responsible for making
the moderation decisions on our platform
but
i kind of thought it was important that
we shouldn't have the final say in the
most important decisions and that there
was like uh you know a
a different body you know the judicial
analogy is something like a supreme
court although obviously you know there
are all these differences here but
something that people can appeal to and
that we can also refer some of the most
complicated cases to and that they can
make the final and binding judgment on
that
and
one of the things that we've seen that i
think has been interesting
is that
it does seem like there's a little bit
more acceptance
when the oversight board weighs in on
something complicated
than when we just do it ourselves and i
think part of that was we put a lot of
thought into making sure that the people
who who are who are on the oversight
board are kind of
world renowned in terms of focus on
human rights really focused on on free
expression as well because at the end of
the day these platforms are about giving
people a voice
diverse
you know spanning a large portion of the
globe but but it wasn't it wasn't
obvious that
it's you know legitimacy isn't like a
binary thing it's not like either it's
completely rejected or it's completely
accepted by everyone you know we were
mindful in setting this up and i i think
the oversight board has also done a good
job itself in in kind of managing its
independence it is a completely
independent organization from us and and
it has to be and and kind of its
independence is super important for its
continued legitimacy overall i'd say i'm
i'm sort of optimistic about how it's
going but i think building that sort of
trust and legitimacy also takes time
it's not like a thing that
you can just turn on in a year and then
all of a sudden people will think okay
this thing exists great it's it's going
to be you know making decisions you know
it often overruling us or rebuking us on
things and people seeing that we respect
its um independence and its authority
and going and implementing that that's i
think how it basically builds legitimacy
over time but i think as an institution
it's really important that we have this
kind of independent function
of course over time
having clear rules set in kind of
democratically elected congress
would be i think the most useful thing
and we're getting that more or less in
different parts of the world
you know obviously it's a little harder
in the in the united states the first
amendment is great so i i'm obviously
hugely supportive of the first amendment
but i think that makes it harder for for
anyone in the united states to to
basically
create or craft different regulations
that that kind of weigh in on some of
these trade-offs but i do think over
time people will will kind of
there will be a balance that is struck
across all of this and like that this is
all part of that moving towards that
equilibrium
you mentioned
cheryl earlier i'd like to come back to
cheryl so this is a question from a
female friend of mine i'll just read it
kind of as as it's written and i'd love
to to hear your thoughts so mark's
business partnership with cheryl is
legendary i can't off the top of my head
think of another partnership like this
male female lasted 15 or so years 15
plus still going
why does it work how does it work why
does he think so very few others have
such a partnership and
i'll just add one more you know what has
shifted in his life and business as a
result so i would just love to hear any
any thoughts on that because it does
strike me also as
a very
unusual
partnership that has been
that has proven itself within tremendous
longevity yeah i mean i think in a lot
of ways
that partnership has defined the growth
of the company and so first of all i
would give a huge amount of credit for
this working to cheryl i think she is an
amazing person and if you think about
where
you know when when she joined the
company
i was like a kid
right i mean it's um she was actually as
old as i am now almost 15 years ago and
and you know i was in my early 20s and
and didn't know anything about
about about business or running a
company or anything like this and
i just think the the kind of
extraordinary amount of patience that
she had and i mean in a way is like as a
manager of an organization it's almost
like she raised me like a child and not
just me i think like a lot of the people
we have on the on the team now
so i mean so i think she's she's
exceptional in that way
one thing that's interesting about our
company
is that the business is sort of oddly
divorced from the actual product right
so most things it's like okay you build
a product and you sell the product and
in our case i think one of the things
that created enough space for someone
who has as much energy and and
is as senior as cheryl to join is the
fact that in in the type of business
that we have the consumer part of what
we do
is actually somewhat distinct from the
advertising and the business part of
what we do so you know there was there
was enough space i think in the company
to have
to have two people right who basically
were like primary principles for the
company and you know i've i've debated
this with a bunch of other peers and
people who've created companies i mean i
know i i
you you had a great podcast with daniel
eck a while ago towards the beginning of
covid and now i've had this discussion
with him a bunch of times he's like i
just couldn't do that right it's like
because he says like literally for for
spotify it's like they they build the
business and the content and all that
stuff is like part of that's like one
kind of package whereas i think we're
sort of uniquely set up where we can i
can focus on the consumer part of what
we do and she can focus on all the
advertising and building the business
and that just has worked incredibly well
over over a long period of time and and
i think will for for for a long time to
come so i just have a huge amount to
learn from her and i think she probably
feels i i guess she feels the same way
but you'd have to ask her
yeah maybe that'll be round two yeah so
i do think that you know the separation
of church and state i mean that's
probably an overstatement but the the
clearly delineated
halves of the company so to speak
lend themselves to that it's a really
good point what are her
superpowers i know that may be a strange
word to use but i think of say warren
buffett referring to charlie munger and
saying he is the best 60-second mind on
the planet right they have very
complementary skill sets slightly
different views of the world although
highly compatible values
what are cheryl's
superpowers that come to mind if any
well i think she has a very good
combination
of
like iq and eq people either i think
tend to be more manager or more
strategic and i think she is
very unique in being both and i just
think that that's pretty rare right and
and obviously if you get if you get
someone who's great at strategy or
graded products and they're not a great
manager that's great right it's like i
mean if you can have someone who's
excellent at one of those things it's
like you hire them every day right so i
think it's just exceptionally rare to
find people who are kind of
spike in both of those areas
i think about this in terms of
she actually uses a lot of dating
analogies i don't but i was talking to a
friend who was single recently and we
were talking about why she was single
and i do just think like some people
want to go through life with
partnerships more than others yeah i
think that there are some people who
like want a co-founder they want a
partner who they can run the thing with
and who can kind of have they can have
that experience with on a day-to-day
basis and then there are other people
who are just like okay
like no i'll just i'll just have a team
of like you know five or six people
around me and like i'll kind of be the
the leader or the founder but i don't
need like a another you know person and
i just think that's that's different
partnership has always meant a lot to me
both in my my personal life and and in
work i like i like want people to be on
the voyage with me right it's like this
isn't like a solo story that's like a
lot of how i derive meaning and in life
and again you'd have to ask her whether
she maybe she's oriented in a similar
way but i think to some degree i think
whether partnerships work over time
probably the number one factor in that
is whether you want the partnership to
work
yes for sure
or if out of the box in a sense you are
predisposed to partnership yeah right
well let's actually use this as a way to
move to a question or just a
observation and then a question that i'd
love to ask and we can take in any
direction you'd like to
so that this is from a
mutual friend who
said one thing that most people don't
know is that his mom is an md but she
stayed home and never practiced medicine
she worked at the front desk of his
dad's orthodontic business which was
which was under their home
and she was wondering you know how these
family dynamics have
shaped who you are today and how you
parent your own children
so that's a big question that could go a
lot of directions i i recognize but i'd
love to hear you to speak to that in any
way that makes sense
so i'd say that that story is partially
true my mom and dad are both doctors and
my mom did practice for a bit but it is
true that when randy my older sister was
born i guess my mom was having a hard
time finding
child care and people who she trusted
enough to raise the kids so she decided
that she wanted to spend more time with
us but my dad's dental office was
attached to the house like you said so
it's just this like magical thing
where and my parents both worked super
hard growing up and were great role
models in that way but also like when i
got home from school i could just like
throw my backpack on the couch and run
downstairs and go see them and my dad
would like be drilling someone's tooth
and like that person was probably not
that happy that i came in and was like
hey dad but uh plenty of stories there
and they were great parents for for for
us growing up they really prioritized
family which is something
that
i definitely took from them and i think
not only did i take it from them
for myself
but it was really meaningful for me
in
basically who i look for as a partner
and priscilla i think is really focused
on this and she obviously has an amazing
career and has way more jobs than i do
in addition to being a parent but the
family orientation is a really big deal
my parents cared that we like achieved
and did great
in in school
but beyond that they didn't really care
what specific thing we were interested
in they just wanted to expose us to a
bunch of things and then
if we were interested in something
then they would try to kind of push us
to be to become excellent at that thing
but you know my mom was never like
you should go fence
she
was just like you know
like sports are good right like go like
go find some some sport and it's like oh
you like fencing it's like all right
well let's get good at that it's like so
i have three sisters and they're all
kind of excellent at very different
things which is it's our family is
i think quite musical
but that's most expressed through randy
who is just an excellent musician and i
guess you can kind of go through the
different siblings i guess i got
computers
that seems to have worked out for you
yeah i i think so i'd say donna's like
the intellectual one
and and l has always been the the kind
of most well-rounded and and social and
athletic of us which is you know as i've
grown up and i've kind of gotten even
more into sports it's been really fun
just getting to to kind of see her how
how much she's how much better she is at
me and like skiing and all these and all
these things that we kind of grew up
together doing but no i i think like
that's that's sort of how i hope to
raise our kids is like
yeah
i mean
i i care a lot they're gonna be good at
school but like but i also care that
they can get exposed to a lot of
different things and and kind of choose
the things that they want to do it's a
fun adventure
one of the things in terms of my
parenting is i try to
no matter what is going on in the day
i i always do bedtime with them i mean i
guess every once in a while i have to
travel although with covet it's been
nice i haven't had to travel that much
so that's
maybe one silver lining of the of the
pandemic the last couple of years but
it's
but basically you know i just take an
hour every day you know we we read we
like
sing we you know it's um you know i'm
i'm reading this book with them now the
way of the warrior kid which is is is
good i recommend just a second is this
jocko it is this is jocko willink look
at that
that's great do you know him too
so jocko's first ever long-form public
interview is on this podcast okay there
you go yeah so i know jocko very well
so this book was recommended to me by
toby ludge the founder and ceo of
shopify
and the girls love it and now they've
started training jiu-jitsu so this is
the stuff you know takes on a life of
its own but it's super fun just having
stuff that we do together every day and
then i always you know
wrap up the day with them
we have this routine
that um that max calls the good night
things which is basically every night we
go through i'm like all right what are
the things that are most important in
life and we go through it it's like it's
health
loving family and friends and something
you're excited about
and like what did you do to help someone
today and and we basically go through
each of these things and it's like all
right so health it's like well what did
you do to like make yourself stronger
more fit today and like if you're if you
get hurt but it's like
max broke her leg skiing once and it's
like okay well like let's go through the
parts of your body that like still work
and that you're gonna like be able to
use while you're recovering and it's
like okay loving family and friends it's
like let's go through you know something
that you did today with a person who is
meaningful to you and then
i think something you're excited about
is and this is actually this is like my
philosophy on life i'm just trying to
like boil it down for them i guess the
the adult version of this is i think you
have to have something that you're
looking forward to for the future i
think that's just a really important
part of keeping people going with the
weight of life but for kids you know it
tends to be something that they're
excited about tomorrow you know more
often than not it's just like all right
i'm excited to see mom in the morning or
like i get to eat cheerios at breakfast
it's like okay it's not not super
inspiring but um but
the right basic idea and then every once
in a while it's something like okay like
max is like i'm gonna get ski poles next
week and it's like okay that's like a
big milestone right or it's like i'm
gonna lose my first tooth right or like
i can't wait until i can like have do
jiu jitsu again
and then the last one i think is
probably the most important which is
like i'm like
we
you know i think especially for our
family but especially for for these
girls who are obviously growing up and
very wealthy family it's like you're
gonna do something nice to help someone
every day right and it's like we like
this is just like an important service
orientation that i just want
you know our our family to have and we
just all go around and like i tell them
something nice that i tried to do to
help someone and and they have to tell
me something nice that they did to to
help someone and it could just be like a
another kid at school or it could be
mom or
or um cousin or or something like that
but probably much to their chagrin i
don't let them go to sleep until they
can tell me something that nice that
they did to help someone that day so
that's probably like the best
encapsulation of how i think about
parenting and the values that i want to
try to impart to them
thank you for sharing all that you know
and i wanted i want to say a few things
number one
toby one of my favorite people i've
known toby
since 2008 or so and people might be
wondering why am i asking about family
why am i asking about parenting and
part of the reason i'm asking is because
many people who listen to this podcast
listen to
model they listen to
model people and i think it's very
important to get a holistic picture of
how people
think about and prioritize things in
their lives and manage things in their
lives because you can end up
if you're not careful say in the realm
of business modeling someone who is from
an external perspective very financially
successful but their
family lives their relationships are in
shambles so i do think that the
micro can
be a reflection of the macro which is
why i like to explore these things so on
the point of things that are important
in life
man i i love that you're reading
jaco's book to your kids it's fantastic
do not well actually no someday you
should roll with jaco he is a black belt
in jiu jitsu and is an absolute killer
probably above your weight class but
worth rolling with nonetheless speaking
of things that are important in life i
would love to ask you about this and
this is going to be a interesting
transition the the sacred and then the
secular and for the secular i have a
very specific kind of technical question
but on the sacred i'd love to ask you
what role religion plays
in your life
if any how do you think about that
it's actually i think playing an
increasing
role in in recent years and so i mean i
was raised jewish
and i think for
i don't know i'd say
from the time i went to college or so
maybe i wasn't as focused on it
but i think a few things in the last
five or six years have made me
a little more focused on it one is of
course family and having kids right so
you like wanna have traditions for
the kids
and a lot of the time it's like okay
well here are the things that i did when
i was growing up
that i thought were meaningful and the
ones that are good do you want you want
to do and the ones that aren't um
you don't but but i i i just found
having that
community and values grounding was was
really valuable so so we are raising our
our our girls to be jewish and that's
that's just become a more important part
of our our lives so it's like every
friday pretty much no matter what's
going on we do shabbat dinner
you know priscilla actually loves this i
mean she's
basically it's sort of a meditative
thing for her but from i think about
tuesday or wednesday she starts carving
out like an hour or so of the day to
like start cooking the shabbat dinner
and basically we have a bunch of friends
over and like and it's it's just like a
real center point of the week
that element i think is more cultural
i'd say for for me personally and for a
company
probably for a lot of people around the
world i mean the last five or six years
have been pretty tough right it's i mean
if you just look at how people felt
about our company
you know before 2016
if you look at like average sentiment
around the company it's like there's
almost like never a month when the
sentiment was negative and since 2016
there's almost never been a month where
the net sentiment has been positive
there have been so many social issues
that have been kind of brought to the
forefront
that you know we talked about this a
little bit before in terms of the
oversight board and how it's important
that it's not just like
you know one person or one company
making all these decisions trying to
balance these complex social equities
but
now part of me is like
i've kind of
gotten an appreciation for why
you know
there just need to be things that are
bigger than you in your life so
even though
our country has a lot of struggles i
probably
believe more in democracy now than i
would have i probably didn't think about
it that deeply before but i just think
like you know believing in in in kind of
democracy in our institutions is like
sort of a bigger force than any
individual i think is sort of a
grounding thing
but i think similarly believing that
there are things that are bigger than
that like god is also just sort of a
really grounding thing for me the more
you sort of study
the bible or the torah or whatever i
mean there's there is like just a lot of
wisdom in it in in terms of you know how
to
live your life how to think about
creation and building i mean no matter
what you're doing no matter how kind of
modern or technological it is
you know i just think there are
interesting
lessons it's really kind of meaningful
to me it's like at the beginning of the
the torah in genesis most of like the
the bible's basically rules for how to
live your life and but it starts with is
like why does it start in this place of
of talking about the creation
and it's like it starts off with like
okay god created people in in god's
image and it's like well what does that
mean what does that mean you're supposed
to go do it starts off talking about
creation right it's like how god created
all the stuff it's like yeah i think
that there's like a real interpretation
in that that
is
kind of personal to me which is like a
lot of what we are here to do is create
good things in the world and i think
that's like very intrinsic to
you know it's like when i'm having a bad
day or a bad month
i just think like there's something
that's sort of
grounded in
it's like no this is like what
i think a big part of what we're here to
do is like build things that make the
world better and i think that is like a
fundamental thing that is sort of
ancient wisdom as people face challenges
in their lives and
as you think about the next generation i
think that these are both
things that tend to ground you and
tie you to much longer arcs and
traditions and that's certainly been the
case in my life
i've actually gone to a number of
shabbat dinners here in austin with
friends of mine and
it's it's made me feel like i have
perhaps a a ritual deficiency
it's such an incredibly grounding
nourishing
tradition i mean outside of the
religious context
and it also what you're saying reminds
me i'm blanking on the book i think it's
four thousand weeks but that's by oliver
berkman and there's a chapter called
cosmic insignificance therapy just the
relief that one can feel
when their time horizon what they're
considering sort of spans outside of
themselves balance is to understand that
there are things that are bigger than
you but what you do still matters
yeah
so i you know i'm going to get to the
secular question and i know we're
running up on time shortly
but in the 2010 new yorker profile which
can't believe everything you read so
we'll see where we go
but
among interests that were cited
here one was eliminating desire
do you recall having this in your
interests and
i i'm curious about this though because
it is very emo that might have been more
of a phase of of life
that was the market you must has paint
my room black you know
all right we could we can chalk that up
to emo so emo emo period check explained
i'm going to get to the technical
question before i get to that though
you did personal challenges
annually for about 10 years
which which challenge
ended up being much easier than expected
and which one ended up being much harder
than expected either or just be curious
to know
i still do stuff like this i don't like
make as big of a deal of it anymore
but i i mean but i think just kind of
throwing yourself into different
situations to learn
new things
i think that's just a big part of life
so yeah well which ones were hard one i
tried to meet a new person every day for
the year
that was hard for me
i'm pretty introverted i built some
amazing
relationships out of it i you know i
started
teaching this class at the local boys
and girls club with a friend and like
mentored the kids for just talked to
them a couple weeks ago they were all
like none of their families had gone to
college before and now they're all
graduating college it's pretty cool
that's amazing but i'm super introverted
so i think that that's probably been
another silver lining of the whole
distributed work thing for me is having
space to kind of think and kind of
control my my time and like not not get
interrupted by other people so much but
it's an interesting balance being
introverted but also
like
being pretty sensitive and caring a lot
about other people i think that people
kind of think that that introverts are
like you know for like don't like other
people or something that's not true i
just should get overwhelmed easily yeah
and then some of the ones
the interesting thing is they all went
in weird directions right so one year
i did this like year of running and
then it's like i just
did all kinds of different running i did
like sprints i did long distance running
and then like my knees started hurting
so then i brought down did triathlons
and training for this iron man but then
i like i broke my arm biking so that
ended up not quite happening so i mean
they all kind of go in in different
directions i learned mandarin one year i
learned mandarin you can't learn
mandarin
it's a challenging one i mean maybe
someone can i cannot you know we talked
about my language deficiency earlier on
but that was partially i like i like
kind of throwing myself into things that
they're hard and you know like like i
said before i mean i've
studied a lot of languages in my life a
little spanish a little
french a little hebrew
a lot of latin a bunch of greek but it's
it's actually hard for me so i kind of
like doing things that are hard for me
and obviously mandarin is is important
because i'm priscilla's family's chinese
so that's
just the day priscilla and i after
dating for almost 10 years had we
decided we didn't want to have like a
big wedding that a lot of people
like we didn't want a lot of people
asking us about it for a while so we did
as a surprise wedding and basically
didn't tell anyone and in the morning of
the wedding we were kind of telling
everyone and i i told
priscilla's mother
in mandarin and i never knew before that
if she understood anything i was saying
and i just told her and a single tear
went down her face and i was like
okay my mandarin is at least good enough
for that wow
yeah they're super interesting a lot of
them have a physical element just
because i
i tend to think like people focus so
much on
thought process decision making like how
can you be as smart as possible but i
just think like energy level and
there hasn't been that much that's been
written about like historical figures
and energy level as opposed to how they
thought but i i actually would be very
fascinated about
about to to kind of understand that but
i i think just
i mean learning how to
how to foil surf and things like that
it's just i mean it's super humbling i
mean these are like really hard skills
it takes like four years before you can
even like get going
and i'm such a beginner
right and it's like it's just wild and
it's so much fun and you know it's like
you start off doing this like
downwinding thing
where i mean the awesome thing about the
foil is like there's almost no friction
compared to a surfboard right at a
surfboard you need to like be in a big
wave or else like it yeah you just stop
but if well you're just kind of standing
on the board but you're actually riding
this little wing and it has no friction
so you can kind of just or very little
friction so you can you can basically
just ride it on open ocean swells and
it's this great workout you just like
can pump in between swells and
you know your heart rate gets up to like
160 but you're you can go for like a
mile or more and it's just it's wild
it's a great workout and you can't think
about anything else while you were doing
it because you will fall immediately so
learning new things is like i think a
big part of what
what brings meaning and joy to life
we'll link to
some of your annual challenges in the
show notes because you've tackled some
very hard things including including
mandarin which is certainly not one of
the easier options out there having
having been an east asian studies major
back in the day all right so i'll ask
the technical question and if you may be
boring but then then we'll we'll start
to wrap up right after that this is a
question from a friend who's a
technologist and he's very curious how
you're thinking about
computing for smart glasses so his
question was this is a bit of a left
turn yet again but with respect to the
metaverse if the phone is one of the
best places to do the computing how do
you think about
navigating
say phones that operate on os's that you
don't control or how are you foreseeing
the future
of that unfolding i think one of the
wildest technical challenges for
augmented reality is that it needs to
basically you need to fit all this stuff
into essentially a normal pair of
glasses but so vr will always you know
it's supposed to be immersive so i mean
maybe it'll eventually be more like ski
goggles right it'll be it'll be kind of
thinner but it's it's not like meant to
just look like you know normal glasses
whereas augmented reality if you're
gonna wear that throughout the day it
really needs to be socially acceptable
so you're basically talking about you
know the normal frames of glasses maybe
called thick rim frames
maybe five millimeters thick right so
within that you're talking about fitting
like you know what would have been
called a super computer five or ten
years ago
you know basically like a laser
projector and then
the the tools to basically have that
display kind of holograms with wave
guides because in order to make sure the
image in the hologram stays synced in
the right place it needs to know what
your eye position is you need like
lasers that understand where your eyes
are and then we need to have speakers
because of course you're going to want
sound um it probably needs microphones
because you're going to want to have an
assistant and talk to it
has sort of positional tracking so that
way if like if you know i'm sitting on
your couch as a hologram and you move
your head i'm not moving off the couch
it like needs to know exactly where
you're looking at so okay all that stuff
need to do all that computation
instantly and glasses that have that are
five millimeters thick so yeah no i
think this is like one of the wildest
technical challenges of the next you
know 10 or 15 years which is why i'm i'm
so excited about it i think there's this
odd thing where i think sometimes people
get
really inspired by physically big things
but i actually think miniaturizing
things to be tiny
is in a lot of ways even a harder
challenge so this is a lot of the work
that's
that's going to happen will it be
valuable to have
another phone or something like that i
don't know maybe i think that there are
you know it's on on the one hand you can
offload computing so that's good one of
the biggest things that basically is a
limiting factor is actually heat
dissipation so if you have a processor
that's running on your glasses and it's
getting hot it's like making your face
kind of warm and that's um uncomfortable
so if you can have that in your pocket
that's better but on the flip side
you need to find a way to get all that
stuff to the glasses and back and
wireless chips are actually pretty
energy intensive too so you're going to
always have some computation on the
glasses
the kind of equilibrium i don't think is
to have all of the computation somewhere
else
and
then you start getting into this
interesting trade-off which is okay well
if you're apple and you have the iphone
is that an advantage and
i think there are a bunch of different
questions in that one is
basically
to what extent are they just going to
advantage their own devices or they're
going to make it so that some of the
apis are open and i think this is
somewhat of a regulatory question right
it's like are they going to be allowed
to just make something that has you know
they have a billion iphones out there
are they going to you know are basically
are the kind of regulated regulatory
agencies around the world going to allow
them to just like only make it so that
their glasses work with their thing it
would seem to me like that there would
be an issue with that but then there's
this other issue
which is if you were designing a
secondary device for say input or
something like that it probably wouldn't
look like a phone exactly right so
i think when new computing platforms
come around
people
tend to assume that the
incumbents
are that that model is sort of going to
work and that whatever the new thing is
just sort of a peripheral to that
existing platform but i think it it kind
of depends you know it's like maybe the
watch is more of a peripheral to your
phone but i would guess that augmented
and virtual reality are so fundamentally
different that whatever you want in your
constellation of devices
you probably want it to be designed
specifically for that and not just like
okay you happen to have a phone so now
let's shoehorn it into into doing
augmented reality too so i know there's
like a lot of interesting questions in
this but i don't know at the end of the
day i think that there's like just a ton
to be invented and there are a lot of
different ways that this could go
thank you mark i appreciate you taking
so much time in what is an incredibly
busy week i can only imagine is there
anything else that you would like to
touch on any requests to the audience
anything at all that you'd like to
chat about or mention before we
bring this to a close
i mean this was a pretty wide-ranging
conversation
i've never had someone start by asking
me about fencing and i don't think i've
ever done an interview where we've
talked to our podcast we've talked so
much about sports i don't know i feel
like we could do a whole nother one of
these i feel like we could i mean we
didn't go into science at all or curing
diseases i know i know
i have a lot of notes left there's a
whole whole another session on that
maybe like another couple of hours at
some point yeah for sure but this is
this has been a lot of fun so thank you
for having me on
of course i really appreciate you being
on and uh making the time for it and
everybody listening we'll also link to
everything in the show notes certainly
and if there are any additional
resources mark that you or your team
would like to put in the show notes we
can add those in the show notes at tim
dot blog podcast
and certainly people can find you online
rather easily i would say facebook zuck
instagram zuck
and uh of course people can find meta
meta.com
and
it's been fun to have a wide-ranging
conversation and as expected i have
many many pages of of topics left that
we could cover and and certainly the the
science and
research side is something that you know
if the opportunity presents itself i'd
love to get into at some point but i
really appreciate you taking time to
have this conversation work this has
been fun thanks for having me
you